il s'appelle jazz il est craquant
il a six mois et demi et vient d'être
élue plus beau bleu russe pour le plus
grand plaisir de sa maîtresse venus
spécialement de paris pour l'occasion
c'est la première fois qu'on fait un
concours que je me lance là dedans avec
mon compagnon
donc on est très très fiers de lui voilà
c'est assez impressionnant et drôle de
se retrouver le feu et quand caroline
parle de son chat elle y met tout son
coeur soleil sacha qui satisfait parce
que je suis ça mettrait femmes et c'est
un très très beau chat qui a des yeux
magnifiquement vert et est un chat très
très calme très affectueux il ya c'est
un chat très agréable anne a quant à
elle fait le déplacement depuis la
région de besançon pour le salon
l'occasion de partager avec les autres
passionnés
comment elle chouchoute son chat guerche
win pour qu'elle est toute son
indépendance
on a fait donc en dehors de la maison
un très grand enclos alors on lui a fait
des tas de choses ddd common des plages
d'observation enfin il est il est très
bien
oui là son jardin lui aménager tout à
fait exprès qui fait 50 mètres carrés
dans ma main ou le précise pas question
de parler budget puisque c'est bien
connu quand on aime on ne compte pas ce
que résume très bien le lisboète marcelo
qui est devenu par hasard elle verra
matters c'est comme un hobby c'est ça
cette fantastique adoré chouchouter
caresser applaudi papouiller ses chats
sont de véritables stars
ils terminent donc leur journée sous les
flashs des photographes